I want to show you some cool stuff that
I basically just figured out two or
three weeks ago and we've already had we
are already having this in production so
and we are currently doing a huge
migration basically killing of our
entire REST API and switching it over to
grass trail so I really want to share my
enthusiasm and you know hopefully
someone else can see the the you know
the positive things about this and use
it in your own projects as well so I
want to show two technologies today one
is graph queue the other one is Apollo
graph scale is kind of one piece of the
puzzle is on the backend Apollo is the
other piece of the puzzle if you use
some JavaScript front-end like angular
or react Jas or react native or just
vanilla JavaScript you can use Apollo as
your client side piece of the puzzle so
Apollo will talk to graph QL and graph
your answer with data and Apollo will
make sure that the data is distributed
to all your components if you want to
get an introduction to these two
technologies best starting point is
obviously the official website and
actually the graphical website is so
cool I don't really need to create any
slides because they've already done it
so we're essentially like okay what's
gradual and you look at it it's like
okay it's a query language for your API
mm-hmm query language sounds like SQL
and stuff like that so how does the
query language look like right and you
see it here it looks a little bit like a
JavaScript object so you basically say
okay I'm going to query a hero and I'm
only interested in the field name and
height and whatever and the response
that you will get looks like this so
it's essentially a JSON string that has
the same structure as the query that you
were requesting and you can you know you
can have nested queries maybe the hero
has a parent and that is also offer type
human so you can you know with using the
brackets you can go deeper and deeper
and deeper and the response will look
the same as well also going deeper in
the same way okay so I mean writing
queries like this is really easy you
don't need to know anything about
database design SQL joins foreign keys
all that stuff anybody can understand
these kind of queries right another
thing is you have only one endpoint when
you think about classic REST API is you
have hundreds of endpoints probably and
the developer
every day when they start working and
they're like okay I need to pick
something on that shop grid okay what
was the shop with end point again is it
all product on product product /
something so you have to go into your
source code or look at your API
documentation find the correct end point
and then learn about what get parameters
are possible and what response will I
get back right and this is really
painful slows me down as hell every day
at work so with glass scale you only
have one end point slash API for slash
gql or slash graft whatever you want and
your application basically these days if
you use something like react J's or
react native its current it's basically
a composition of hundreds of small
components right and react you build
tons of components and each of these
components they will have small queries
of you know these kinds of queries here
of the data that they want to consume
like imagine you have a website on the
top right corner there's avatar icon and
other Chinese like the URL of the
picture and maybe first name last name
to render that at the top of the website
so you would write a query like user
first name last name avatar thumbnail or
something like that right and you have
tons of components and they all have
these queries with normal REST API it's
when I open my luxe gloss mobile app it
sends 15 HTTP requests to my API I mean
I should probably optimize that somehow
but you know most people who just
goofing around with mobile apps they
will they will do it like this right
with graph QL I only have one request
because Apollo the client will batch all
the requests in in a queue and every 10
milliseconds it will take all of them
and merge them into one huge thing that
looks like this right so I will have
tons of small components they all have
small queries like this this can be
combined into one big string that
contains everything and it will be like
one request that is sent to your graph
your back-end and one response coming
back with all the data that you have
requested also with classic REST API
endpoints when I go to like slash
products and I get a list of all my
products usually I get like seventy
fields I have like our database is
pretty big these days and we have lots
and lots of potential kind
of information that we store for each
product and my rest endpoint it returns
just everything about that product even
though when you have to shop great what
what do I see picture price title that's
it and then you click into the product
and then you want to see all these other
50 things right and here you just define
exactly what you want and and what's
being sent back over the wire is exactly
what you have requested and nothing more
so you not only save requests which is
like HTTP requests have to be build up
its overhead all the time
you also save bandwidth and you save
space on the device because it's less or
data that you have to save and memory
right so this is pretty awesome
basically the people on the back end and
I won't talk about this today their task
is to create the schema to describe how
your data looks like and it doesn't
matter what database you are using it
could be Postgres could be MySQL could
be MongoDB it could be there could be
even some endpoints here with fields
that you are taking from the Twitter API
so you know your API could talk talk to
another API and you can still query it
in the same way like here right because
under the hood on the backend what
people will write in whatever language
they use these are these things resolved
by using normal programming functions
and you can do in those functions
whatever you want you can do it as you
can do SQL query or you can do a request
to some other endpoint okay so basic
okay and because we have this schema
here Brasel understands how your what
data you have and there is a small web
tool it's like an IDE that allows you to
try out these queries and while you type
it gives you code completion and because
it understands that there's something
like all films in your schema and it has
name and climate and whatever okay here
this is the planet it will when you say
give me all films and then for each film
give me title and opening crawl whatever
this means here so it while you're
typing this it already shows you what
fields are available you don't ever have
to look at any documentation you could
throw a new developer at your project
don't tell them anything just give them
this and they type the first opening
bracket and they see whatever is what
endpoints are available right they
choose an endpoint they type the next
bracket they see what what what type is
in there
they type the bracket again they see
what fields are available to sort of
speak what columns are available in your
database right you could just press the
docs button here okay now it's here and
you can see what-what are my end points
in each end point what is the return
value what data types are each field and
those return values so and I and you
don't have to write a single line of
code to get this kind of documentation
so believe me when you use this you're
like efficiency will skyrocket
immediately right okay I hope I could I
sold you on this so the other piece of
the puzzle is that's a back end right
and we are not here today the four back
end stuff we are here for front end
stuff and JavaScript stuff so Facebook
invented all this and Dave they release
something called relay itright relay
like two months ago when I already
understood that this will be good for me
but I totally fail and like after four
hours I still couldn't get my react
components to render anything from my
database so I gave up I ranted on
Twitter and then everybody on Twitter
said hey bro why don't you just use
Apollo it's like relay but easier so I
tried that two weeks ago and it was
easier indeed right after like 20
minutes I I could see something and then
I went down the rabbit hole and now I'm
sitting here so the poor documentation
is quite ok you basically choose what
front-end framework you are using and
then you know just follow the initial
steps how to install usually these these
things here usage examples these are the
ones in the documentation if you want to
read about and then you might might need
to dig deeper every now and then you
will go here into the API reference and
learn how it works internally more under
the hood to do some more magic stuff
like pagination and so on ok so much
about the introduction so basically in
this talk I will mostly copy and paste
code from my slides into my editor
because I'm too slow at typing to get
this done in half an hour and basically
if you want to try this at home you can
just get these slides and you basically
you know do the same that I'm doing
right now here so I basically want to
show you it's possible you can try it
you know first of all if you clone this
repository you will have to install a
virtual environment with Python so you
need to
a little bit about pythons or just
Google that install all the requirements
and then you should be able to run a
local Python server that should look
something like this
so manage my runs over and you should be
able to go to this URL and you should be
able to go to graphical and you know and
then you're like hmm what endpoints are
there right so okay there's some
endpoint that gives me all messages and
one endpoint that gives me one message
so when I go to all messages that's
pretty pie that all right
what else do I need to do okay there's
something like edges and something like
node I don't really know what it means
aha this is what I need ID creation date
so these are the database columns that
my message table provides right when I
execute this I'm getting a JSON string
with all my messages from my database
all right
so and this is how I would start working
essentially I decide what I what kind of
component I'm going to work on today and
I figure out what query do I need so
that this component can render later
figure out the cream here and when I'm
done and copy and paste that query into
my actual code so we see we will see
that later so basically that this Django
server that I provide in the repository
is just so that you have a graph graph
your API back-end available for you to
play around with and it only has these
three endpoints like all messages one
message and create a new message we will
see that and at the end so so if you
wanted to now you know start using
react.js and apollo first thing you need
to do is create and react jazz
application and these days this is
pretty easy you can do NPM install
global create react app and then you
execute create react app and you give it
a name so you would do that when you
clone my repository right there is
already a front-end folder you can
delete that folder and then start from
scratch again doing this right I don't
want to do this now because it's almost
a lot of stuff from NPM so I just
imagine I've already I've just done
create react app
front end okay and it creates the front
end folder that's all it does
okay so let's go into that folder and if
it has worked you should be able sorry
you should be able to do yarn start and
this will open your browser and there is
your react
jas application that doesn't do anything
right now okay so this is how you can
start a new react project but we want to
use Apollo and I want to show a list of
items and then you click into one item
you see the detailed view and I want to
have another page in my app where you
can create a new message so we need
three pages and for that something like
react router is commonly used so we also
need to install react router so while
you are here in your front and folder
now we are in front and you would do
your yarn at react router dumb and react
Apollo I've already done that so I want
to that again did I actually do it
Anette correct router dumb ok maybe not
I'm not sure
okay so we are still in the setup phase
of our project right we are still not
really doing anything related to Apollo
and graph show but we should have
installed all the necessary
prerequisites at this point in time and
now we need to you know make sure that
this default react application that we
can see here shows something that we
actually build ourselves so I will
basically remove these imports here and
I will remove whatever is in here and
now the beauty of this create react app
is did I stop the server yeah I did the
beauty would have been that it
automatically refreshes whenever you
save your file alright so now it's empty
and the first thing that we need to do
when when we want to start using this
awesome
Apollo and crafts QL stack and react
router we need to add a bunch of imports
at the top of our file okay so we always
have in every react.js application we
have react import at the very top and
then here we have to import three things
that are related to Apollo here we have
to import three things that are related
to react router and here is our three
views that we want to build today these
files don't exist right now okay so we
have these imports then we have to do
some boilerplate code that you know I
don't even know what it does this is
what you find on the on the Apollo
tutorial on the official website so
essentially we have to use this create
batching network interface function to
create a network interface and we have
to tell it and this is the important
part where what is the URL of our graph
CL endpoint so of your back-end server
right this is the batching that I
mentioned when you have a lot of
components with lots of queries that
will be put into a queue and you can
define how many milliseconds Apollo
should wait before it grabs all the
queries merges them into one big one and
sends them to the server so if you have
some kind of add like a game or whatever
that generates
like requests on a per millisecond basis
but you don't really need to send all
these requests in real time you could
you know set the best values to some
milliseconds value here and this is this
allows you to send additional HTTP
headers to your server let's ignore that
for today and then you just create an
instance of Apollo client and then this
is on the next slide we will replace our
render function with this fancy code
okay I have some syntax errors oh yeah
this is because of my slides okay what's
the problem here
render return should we find okay
there's one record missing all right so
we have told Apollo where our API
endpoint is and we have this Apollo
client instantiated and now we
essentially wrap our entire react
application in between this Apollo
provider component and we pass in the
client that we have instantiated into
that component
who cares what this does below the right
it works and it looks beautiful so just
do it
same for react router you basically have
to wrap your entire app in between react
router component unfortunately the react
router component can only have one child
component so I cannot do this this would
mean we have one to child like routes
and switch right we have to put one diff
around everything and then here
basically react router with version 4
with the new API works like this if the
current URL is slash then at this space
at this position in our HTML code like
right behind this this render the home
view component okay but if the URL is
messages create then we will render that
component so it kind of switches on and
off which component is currently
rendered okay and the switch thing let's
ignore it for today it's basically
because these two routes here they could
be the same if you go to
just slash create messages slash ID is
also a match because this is a variable
part in my URL right and maybe slash
create is the variable part in my URL so
and then you know I was like hey why why
is it displaying both components at the
same time and then I looked into the
reactor rota documentation I figured out
if you switch it goes down the list one
by one and if it finds a match it stops
and it only renders the component that
it has found so this way you can make
sure if you have ambiguous routes that
could be like overlapping that it only
renders the one that defines first okay
so this is like a typical like all my
react applications and also my react
native applications the outermost entry
point of your app looks always something
like this all these kinds of wrapper
components that add magic to your
application okay okay so this will still
not work because we have been importing
three files that don't exist right now
so I create a folder views and I create
three files home view yes and
detail view and create view alright and
I mean these views are supposed to be a
react component so we need to put a
little bit of code inside so that they
just do anything at all so I just
changed the name of the class and put
some title here so that I can
distinguish them by like when we test
them so we will have home view and
finally hey where's my to tell you
and while I was doing all this
it kept refreshing the background that
it's just now that was an error message
right and now suddenly what's working
again I love this so I could go to
messages one and it's the detailed view
rendering now I could go to messages
create and is to create view rendering
right and I can just go to the home page
as a homely rendering so like our add
skeleton is up and running so this is
kind of the painful stuff that took us
ten minutes that you need to do every
time you start a new react project but
you know it's not it's not that hard
right okay so now we can do the exciting
things so we want to learn about Apollo
right and graft kale so first thing we
want to do is how do I create some data
I want to see some data out of my
database on my website right so let's
start with the home view first thing you
do is you import gql and graph view from
react Apollo and gql is basically I
don't know it's just like a function
that requires this kind of JavaScript
string literal and this is exactly the
query that in the morning when I started
working I figured out in the graphical
editor right you can copy and paste this
exact query into here alright so and
then we need to change our render
function to actually use the data that
we now have accessible in our component
so let me paste in this new render
function so alright so who has used
react yes let's quick show of hands oh
wow that's good that's like maybe 60% so
most people will be familiar with this
kind of syntax each react component
right has this properties inside of this
class I can always use this drops so
these are things that have been passed
into the component by some outside
component okay so basically like if I
would do something like this
this info equals hello then and let's
say this was my own live component then
I could do this props info
inside of my own disc component right so
this is how you have to imagine how the
properties work and because of graph QL
we will have a field called data like we
will have this props data available in
our component because we enhanced our
component was graphical is Apollo ok
and the cool thing is data is another
JavaScript object that has lots and lots
of information in it and one part is
loading so while your request is still
in flight loading is going to be false
and when the request came back loading
is going to be true and when the request
came back loading will turn to false
right and every time a property changes
the render function will be called again
this is how react works so in the
beginning when you first load your page
there is no data so the query will be
sent loading will be true and we will
just return some you know loading stuff
this is kind of like when you go through
the Facebook homepage you can see in a
timeline that there are these grey boxes
like these fake posts while it's still
loading and this is the kind of stuff
that you would return here right you
would return some kind of fake
representation of the data that you will
show soon but it's not there yet
okay so once loading is done we we
instead of rendering this we will render
this right and so and we will have now
access to this the props that data dot
all messages which is the name of the
end point that we have created here okay
and then we know that we have to do
edges dot node to get to the actual item
and edges is a list of items so we can
map over that list and for each item in
that list we will render a paragraph and
put a link inside so that we can click
into that item so so in this case item
is one edge right and we know that
inside an edge that is note so I will
have to do item node dot ID so this ID
is basically the data that I have
requested right and this message down
here is also the data that I have
requested in my query all right so
hopefully
huh oh yeah that that happened when I
tried this earlier so I'm prepared for
this I'm not prepared for this undefined
oh yeah of course we need to go to the
next slide first or actually we need to
paste everything in this slide so the
last part of the puzzle is this
component currently doesn't know
anything about this query right this is
just a stupid react component doesn't
know anything about Apollo or whatever
so and this is why we imported graph QL
we use gql to create our query graph
scale is kind of a function wrapper or
decorator all ever you want to call it
and unfortunately you could use this
graph QL query if you are like
bleeding-edge super-modern yes whatever
syntax but when you use create react app
on the command line the bubble configure
word or the es lin config is configured
in such a way that you cannot use the
decorator syntax yet so unfortunately
this would be like super beautiful we
have to do it in the manual way so we
call the graphical function we put in
our query variable right and we wrap our
react component into that so now this
graph fuel magic is wrapped around our
component and this makes sure that this
prompts the data and all this magic is
available and hopefully bam we can see
data okay so now the next thing you will
ask yourself hmm how do I create queries
where certain parts are variable like if
we go to this URL this part of the URL
is dynamic write this this dictates what
kind of data I have to create from my
database this is like the ID of the
object okay and we can do that pretty
simply so this is going to be our
detailed view and once again first thing
we do is we put the query in here and
now it looks a bit different
we have to write the keyword query and
we have to say this is a query for my
detailed view and actually you can come
up with any name you could also call
this product detail or anything right I
haven't really come up with a good best
practice yet how to name these things so
I like to name them in the same name
like the component is like this is the
query for this component right so so far
this has worked for me pretty well and
I'm saying that this query has variables
okay
and it means there's one variable that's
called ID and the type is this special
kind of graph QL ID so you see these
weird strings here
those are graphical IDs you could have
more things like you could say this
thing also has I don't know limits and
it's an int and it's a mandatory field
so this is how you define your variables
and then there comes the bracket and
then it's the normal way how you would
create things from your endpoints right
so you would usually go and you can
basically exactly the same thing that
you just saw there we can also write it
down here so we can say a query any name
or web sorry query any name needs a
variable ID of type I D is mandatory and
when I execute this query I want to call
my message endpoint and I want to
clearly filter by ID using my ID
variable okay and whatever I get back I
want to have the ID the creation date
and the message so I can't run that yet
because there is no variable okay so
when you have queries with variables you
need to define them down here in the
variable window and once again super
smart it already detects what variables
I defined up here and suggest them for
me and then you just fill in the
variable and you run your query and
voila you get your data and then you
copy and paste this whole thing into
your react code and
work just like that so the other way
around is usually the case you try
typing it here and it doesn't work and
then you're like that why does it work
and then you go to graphical you paste
it in here and you get some nice error
messages here okay so that's the first
step we define our query second step
again is to use the new data in our
render function alright so same thing
right
while my query is still in flight I'm
rendering some loading stuff once I got
my data I have access to data
so this drops the data and the message
because that is the end point the
graphical end point that I've created
right and then dot ID creation date
message because those are the fields
that I have requested so I have exactly
that data available in my HTML markup
well in my render function okay and then
I probably still oh yeah
so the decorator part is a bit more
tricky now all right so we have to read
this from the bottom up just like before
we are using the graph QL decorator
right we are passing in our query and in
this case we are passing in another
JavaScript object with some extra data
some options for my query and then we
wrap our component in that wrapper
function okay so far so good
so how does this other extra options
object look like so it's a JavaScript
object and it has a key options and this
can be an anonymous function so this
syntax here might confuse a few people
this book sorry this basically means our
options isn't just a string or whatever
this is actually an anonymous function
and the first parameter of that function
is the properties of my component okay
and so this function returns another
javascript object where the first key is
variable and then I have one variable
called ID and I'm now using props that
match the parent ID so this is because
of react router okay because we wrapped
our
application in between react radda radda
radda does some cool magic and make sure
that all my components have this props
match available and if my URL had any
variable parts so like if you use this
coal on something right this is one of
the parents so I have dot match parent
dots ID all right so that means this is
how I can access this outside
information from the URL and getting it
into my react component and now I'm
passing it into my query variables for
grass ql to consume okay so let's see oh
wow it already updated itself so we can
now go into each of our things here and
it will display the value from the
database okay
and now this is something that I want to
show you so I refreshed now let's let me
go to the home page first so i refresh
the page I get one request for graph
here okay and I get back the result I go
into the first object it's another
request against my web server I go back
to this page no more requests because
Apollo because Apollo remembers what
kind of data types do I have so in our
case is the message object and what IDs
do they have and it keeps the cache of
all of them okay so if I go into the
second one we have never seen that one
yet so it's another it's another request
if I go back to the home page no more
requests if I go into the third one is
another request and now no matter what I
do I click around in my app no more
requests but everything is in cache so
that you get all this magic for free
it's like really helpful for you know
mobile applications where if the person
is on a train for example the network
suddenly gone those merits we can still
you know move around user profile and
and the latest tweets or whatever and
can still see stuff alright so the final
thing that I want to show today is
how do you write data we have understand
we can understand now how to query data
even with variables so how do we write
data in the graph QL world this is not
called a query this is called a mutation
and so that's why you have to write
mutation and then as before I give it a
name so this is the mutation for the
create view right and if you want to
create a new message there's one field a
text field where you type in your
message so this is kind of like the form
data that we are about to send to our
graphical
endpoint and we say like the variables
called message type string and this is
the endpoint of our graph QL schema so
we would do like mutation like new
developer no clue was in system press
control space I only have one mutation
so it already completes to that one
mutation that's available I press record
it already tells me you need to provide
a message right as a test and when you
send a request to mutation end point it
comes back with a result as well so what
is the result it has two fields actually
form errors and a message and we know
that a message is also part of our
schema so we might only want to have the
ID because you know I want to save the
message get back the new ID and then you
could like refresh the page and go to
the newly created detailed view of debt
ID okay or actually in our case I would
just go back to the home page so you
know you can try that one oh it's even
hey wait this should work
oh no of course it works yet because I
provided my variable here already okay
so
and I know this is pretty hard to digest
now it's already a lot of codes and
you're all tired but we are almost done
only like two more slides with code and
then we are done in my component I will
I will define a submit handler so when
the form is submitted
I need to do some magic right and first
of all I will prevent whatever the
normal HTML form would do I will just
stop that event then I just use the HTML
form data API to fetch all the data from
my input fields there's only one field
that's called message right and now
because of Apollo and because of the
decorator that we will use at the end we
have this props mutate available okay
because this is a mutation and we
provide the variables that are necessary
you know we have defined that our
mutation requires a variable so we pass
in that variable by using that form data
thing again and this is a promise so
when you call mutate is a promise when
the promise resolved so you say dot then
in the end oh sorry
whatever does okay
when the promise resolved you get access
to the return query here right so you
get access to a rest data create message
and then there might be something inform
errors or maybe not if there are no form
errors and there might be something in
message if you are successfully created
a message I think if I don't provide any
text here there is something in form
errors please provide a message okay I
designed the graph QL back end that way
so I will basically basically just check
if there are formed if there are no form
errors I will redirect to the home page
if there are four errors you know you
would usually use something like this
dot set state errors and then you put
the form errors in here so when you set
the state your component re-renders
right then you would you know put some
kind of form errors component down here
so when the componentry renders the form
error appears okay so this is a it's
really up to you how you
actually display the form errors in your
application okay so that was a that was
the submit handler and then like in the
other examples I will replace the render
function with something more meaningful
so I'm essentially just displaying a
simple form like this just one form and
one button right so this is a very
normal HTML form it has two HTML input
elements inside and it has this on
submit handler here which is the
function that we have created up here
okay yeah so oh yeah and before this
works we have to grab our component in
the Apollo decorator and we have to
remove the export default here so this
is the same thing as before right we use
the graphical decorator with this query
in this case with this mutation that we
have created and we wrap our components
and inside so now hopefully there it is
it works
[Applause]